yesterday we had a really interesting
conversation with pedro and we've got
alex on on the call now and alex is our
resident expert in colonels and you said
you were particularly excited about this
colonel paper from pedro
i was when i first read this paper i was
like super pumped
um you know i obviously i think kernels
are kind of an interesting thing
um in general but along comes this paper
that kind of
really explains how a lot of the big
movements in in deep learning
as well as um a lot of things i've kind
of seen in like in my work over the
years to do with deep learning how they
all kind of fit together
i mean we kind of assumed that that deep
learning must have something to do with
kernel methods because there's all that
stuff about uh you know neural tangent
kernels etc
but here we finally have a really good
proof of exactly the mechanics behind
all this and how it happens what's super
exciting here
is that deep learning models are no
longer black boxes they're kind of more
like gray boxes they're certainly not
like interpretable
but now we understand the mechanics
behind how it all fits together
that's a big step forward fantastic
amazing well um
i just wanted to put a quick caveat in
so with the conversation with pedro he
is quite a controversial figure
and certainly a lot of the stuff that i
was talking about especially when i'm
talking about um
what what we might call wokism and i
don't mean that in a drug a tree um
sense a lot of my information from that
came from reading helen pluck rose
she wrote that book recently and i just
want to make it clear that i'm not an
expert in this
clearly i i have a view which i've built
up after reading that book and i'm
i'm willing to have my view changed but
i don't want
you to interpret this as as me speaking
authoritatively because i'm really not
i was quite worried going into this
conversation because
you never know how it's gonna turn out
right and
and you know pedro is quite outspoken
for example
on twitter and so on and a lot of people
i think you know rightfully criticize
his behavior there as you know something
a lot of people would like to see kind
of more moderate discussion more nuanced
points which
is a question if that's even possible
you know
on twitter i think it turned out quite
well in that
we show that you can actually still have
a conversation even if you
disagree there is a danger in having
these conversations in that
it often devolves into sort of camp-ism
uh because you know you divide people
into
the woke camp and whatever the left camp
and the right camp and
i i don't think we can help it i don't
think like at some point these
discussions need to be about okay there
is a viewpoint
that is held by a certain number of
people and now we're going to argue
against
that viewpoint but we should never
forget that
people are individuals and everyone
you know no one is the group
everyone has their own point and i think
even during a conversation
listening to a conversation like this
it's almost inevitable you fall into
groupism but
you know everyone as a person and i
think that's really important to
remember
i think online the the temperature in
these conversations gets turned up quite
a bit
we have conversations all the time and
disagree about things and there's never
any heat in it
because fundamentally we understand
people have differences of opinion
social media as an amplifier takes these
disputes and uh
it makes it very dangerous and very
poisonous very quickly because
the human face on the other side
disappears
exactly but but you see like in the
conversation
we not like we can't help but sort of
devolve into oh these people say that
and
just going with they right and even
like even we like not elevating us but
even we
kind of forget that you know every one
of those people
thinks differently it's it's really hard
even to have these long-form
conversations so
as you know everyone who's listening
today take everything
with a grain of salt welcome back to the
machine learning street talk youtube
channel
and podcast with me tim scarf and my two
compadres
mit phd dr keith duggar
and janik lightspeed culture
now today we have professor pedro
domingos
we're going to talk about wokeness
activism in machine learning
cancel culture ai ethics and last
but not least kernels in pedro's book
the master algorithm
he segmented the ai community into five
distinct tribes
with five unique identities and before
you ask
no the irony of an anti-identitarian
doing so was not lost on me
but those identities were symbolists
connectionists
evolutionaries bayesians and analogizers
and god knows we've had representation
from all of those five groups on the
show
and as pedro points out the bayesians
are overwhelmingly
the most passionate now pedro recently
published an article in quillette
called beating back cancel culture a
case study from the field of artificial
intelligence anyway domingo has railed
against wokism political activism in the
machine learning community
and cancel culture and recently he was
involved in a controversy
where he asserted that the europe's
broader impact statements
were an ideological filter anyway
professor pedro domingos it's an
absolute pleasure
welcome to the show thanks for having me
it's great to be here
well the coolett article is based on my
experience with you know being a target
of a cancel attack
which was quite interesting but also
quite instructive and
you know the editor of colette or the
executive editor colin wright he
contacted me even as it was happening
right
they're clearly very on top of twitter
and asked me if i wanted to write a
piece about the incident
and i said yes and then i thought what
would be the most useful thing to do
and i thought you know the incident per
se maybe is not that
interesting uh it's it is however
interesting as an
exemplar of a larger phenomenon and
the you know the the episode was nice in
that
they attempted to cancel me but they
wound up getting cancelled themselves
so it shows that you can turn the tables
and so what i wrote was an article with
basically a series of points about
you know my hub based on my experience
and also other things that i know but
illustrated by this episode on how you
can fight back against cancer culture
because a lot of people are very
fatalistic and pessimistic they say oh
there's nothing
you know we can do you just have to hide
and actually i don't believe so you can
fight back against them and defeat them
so in a way the article is a little you
know set of
points for how to fight back each of
them illustrated with what happened
in the in this episode i think it'd be
really good to go through some of those
points
but what i wanted to say just as an
aside is when i invited you on this show
i used to work in the tech industry and
one of my female ex-colleagues she
reached out to me on twitter
and she said that um i heard that you're
talking with pedro domingos and you know
he's a dinosaur he's going to be on the
wrong side of history and
apparently you retweeted an article um
saying that there was
um no evidence of bias against women or
something like that so you always have
this thing in the background where
okay so you've overcome cancer culture
but
your name seems to be stained forever
now so how do you
wrestle with that uh well i thank the
cancel
mob for staining my name forever i
consider it an honor
you know if they say i'm a dinosaur on
the right side of history that actually
shows to me that i'm doing something
right because in fact i believe that
they are the dinosaurs they think
they're the future but they really
the dead cat bounce of a 21st century
ideology
and you know the more they rail against
me the more satisfied i am
well i think on this brings up something
that is probably
my biggest problem with uh cancel
culture is that let's suppose they're
right that you are a dinosaur
i mean just maybe you are we study
dinosaurs
right i mean even though even though
dinosaurs aren't that advanced or
whatever we still apply
science to them we apply logical
argumentation
we study them etc the biggest problem i
have with cancer culture is it's
it's a form of intellectual laziness and
cowardice
it's like i can't i can't address this
thing
i'm seeing here there's some type of
impedance in my mind or maybe i just
you know i'm too lazy to address it so i
just want to ignore it and i want
everybody else to ignore it too
so i don't hear about it you know it's
it's the it's the children putting their
fingers in their ears going la
la la la la la like i can't hear you um
that's
you know that's where the crux of the
problem with cancel culture from my
perspective
well i mean to be honest uh maybe we are
the dinosaurs maybe they are
right right i don't know so the way we
found that is by actually debating it
but of course the problem starts with
the fact that they do not allow debate
a very central part of this ideology is
that if you disagree with them that
proves that they write
right there's these testimonies from
students in the classes of some of these
people saying like why am i not allowed
to disagree
right i mean even even in this you know
you know
after this discussion i've seen episodes
with like people who are ai researchers
on twitter basically saying like no
no to other people you are not allowed
to disagree with her
so first of all we have to establish the
fact that you can debate
but of course this is part of one of
it's one of the things that they're
trying to kill
and i think ever you know like we all
have our different ideas on ai and on
politics
but what we should all be able to agree
on is that you know we should
discuss them we should be able to
discuss them and
allow out to and that's where you know
sunlight will come from
we should all agree that you have to
stop cancel culture cancer culture is
about canceling something in particular
canceling debate and that's the first
thing they wish to agree must not happen
and i love this i actually love the term
cancel culture because it describes
i think people are focused on the
cancelling but i really want to make a
point that it is a culture by now so i
have
made a video on one of your papers the
gradient descent models or kernel
machines
paper which i have it's a straight up
academic
review of a paper and my opinions about
the paper
and someone expressed their opinion
saying given how toxic pedro has been
on twitter i'm surprised that you are
giving
him a platform so to speak and
so 100 i'm sure
this person means no harm it's
like in it it is not it is
like it is in the culture like it is so
obvious
to that nowadays that you can do this
that you can say we don't have to you
know
look at these academic ideas because the
person
behind it has you know some dirt on them
and that is it's a sad state honestly
no and the amount of dirt keeps ever
shrinking
and the consequences keep ever
increasing so somebody says one thing
that somebody in the castle culture
doesn't like and that's grounds for
firing them and
and you know there are many examples of
this at this point
i also really uh you know i agree with
your point that the count the
the council is interesting but the
culture is the most important part
and in fact the culture is the most
alarming part
because it is a whole culture and and
you know it's easy to dismiss these
people as like oh the children are
restless
but this has gone way beyond that this
is not just restless children anymore
it checked with something very dangerous
to use a biology analogy and you know
they're popular these days you can ask
is cancer culture more like a virus or
more like a cancer
it's much more like a cancer right a
cancer is something that's actually
organized enough to grow
and then kill its host organism not like
a virus right you know and in a way
virus is easy to do with any cancer
so cancel culture has you know all the
components of the culture
and you know fighting it is a little bit
like fighting an octopus but you know
you cut off the legs one by one or the
arms one by one and
and i think that's what we have to do i
was going to ask um
because i think there are elements of
religion in woke-ism you know there are
high priests and
i think it's very seductive i think a
lot of people that would have been
evangelical christians or something have
kind of taken to this ideology and it
you know it does come from these
foucaulian ideas i think foco was the
epitome of these ideas and he wasn't
interested in activism it became
applied in activism in the late 1980s
but there's this knowledge principle
right which is that it's a construct of
language
and there's the political principle
which is that absolutely everything that
happens in our society
should be interpreted through these
interlocking
um kind of structures of power and we
should be training ourselves to see
everything in this way is is that just
reductionist
people when they get hit by cancel
culture and when they see its
manifestations as they have exploded
to public view in the last couple of
years they're often completely
flabbergasted
because none of it remotely makes any
sense but if you understand
postmodernism you actually it all makes
sense to you
it you you realize how evil it is but
you have you know like
you have to remember that fuco is
probably one of the top few most cited
people ever right there's this whole
fields that have gone up since the 60s
that are basically following his ideas
and and and you know and those of other
postmodernists but he's he's
you know arguably the most important one
and and the central idea
where there's the number of of them but
probably the single most important
centrality to what they do is that there
is no such thing as objective reality
right when you try to engage these
people inside like but wait
what is the evidence that all whites are
racist
right this is a common one or that all
men are sexist and they are not
interested in evidence because you know
like the the whole idea of validating
your beliefs
against real data is is not important
right so this is the this is an ideology
that has grown up
and you know that it's a complex
phenomenon right there's multiple
strengths but a very essential one is
that
they and and to your point it is very
much like a religion in that these
beliefs
are not available to be questioned which
would be bad enough if they were correct
but unfortunately are also incorrect
yeah because i think it's really
impenetrable because they use
so much technical jargon and people
switch off and they spout off all of
these
clever phrases from foco and you know
um you could argue that it enables some
kind of mediocre minds to be very
successful in that academic world that
perhaps wouldn't be so successful
otherwise but
you know you were talking about the the
white fragility thing i mean
that's really annoyed a lot of people as
well because it's basically saying that
you know white people have this
internalized um you know kind of
racism if you like and we're completely
unaware of it there's nothing we can do
about it
it creates a lot of resentment it it
implies that
a white person is privileged even if
they have no money at all even if they
have no opportunities they are just
automatically privileged
and as a white person i can't have an
opinion on anything because anything i
say
is part of this meta narrative there's a
there's a white
supremacist discourse and anything i say
is part of that discourse and it's
almost like i don't exist as an
individual and nothing i say has any
value
you can't really move from that position
can you no i mean exactly so another
part of this ideology is that there is
no such thing as an individual
you are just part of a group everything
about you is explained by the
intersecting set of groups that you're a
member of which is where the whole idea
of intersectionality comes from
and again another very postmodern idea
this one more from the reader is that
everything is cast in terms of these
binaries
one of which is the oppressor and one of
which is the oppressed
so you know in in gender men are the
oppressor women are depressed in race
whites where the oppressor
blacks are depressed you know etc etc
and and and
everything is formulated in these terms
and then what's happened is that again
a little bit like biology this is
something that has been growing
in the wild and generating you know
think of it as memes instead of genes
right
this thing has been breeding for decades
and what happens
when you let that happen is that you
finally you know
things evolve and the ones that are most
successful at
imposing themselves on people's minds
actually survive
right and the early generation of
postmodernism was actually
not very effective at propagating it it
was
i mean like you know quick parenthesis
right i got my phd at uc irvine i went
there because it had
you know one of the few large machine
learning groups in the world at the time
completely by coincidence uc irvine was
also one of the leading lights
in critical theory it had this thing
called the critical theory institute
where they brought in the rita and
leotard and you know every quarter there
would be a different one of these
postmodernists
and i went to some of their classes
because i had nothing better to do
right so i set in on the reader i set it
on leotard
and you know little did the california
taxpayers know that their money
was being used for this and i talked
with the students in their classes right
many of which were like
i don't believe any of this crap i was
like like do you really believe this
come on like at lunch right after the
class
and they're like no of course not but i
need to get a phd
so i'm going to pretend that i believe
this until i graduate and have a
position and then right
and and and the thing is that like
this was incredibly enlightening to me
and i was and i you know i read
so-called's book and whatnot so as this
thing has unfolded over the last
couple of decades none of it is really
that surprising
but but part of what's happened is that
this initial ideology was i'm like
the reader is like a stand-up
entertainer the whole thing is like a
joke
and we're both in on the joke and and
none of it can be taken seriously so
like so the first generation of
postmodern was like born out of the
disappointed with marxism and the whole
idea that you could have strong beliefs
about something was kind of you know
not in right but over the decades of
course
that doesn't have a lot of you know
propagative ability
that has been replaced by the people who
are you know hardcore
about now we're going to impose these
ideas and then
the ones that had prevailed over the old
kind of
and the the big thing is that the old
kind of postmodernism yes you know your
taxpayers money was being wasted on that
which and you know
that class of people most of them very
mediocre as well very well point
out but you know we can live with that
the problem today is that this is not
very violent and you know they are
trying to take over
society and increasingly succeeding so
again
to pursue the analogy with cancer the
longer you wait to fight it the harder
it becomes
yeah you know tim you brought up kind of
the manipulation of
of language i mean and pedro you
mentioned the connection to
marxism you know this is exactly what
orwell wrote about
uh you know back in the in the 40s right
for example if you read a
fantastic essay called politics in the
english language you know he talks about
this kind of inflated
um style of writing right the kind of
latin nation of that the complexity
of everything that that itself is this
this form of euphemism
and he he has a great quote he says uh a
mass
of latin words fell upon the facts like
a
soft snow blurring the outline and
covering up all the details right like
that's what it's about is making it so
obfuscated and so vague that by the end
you're not even really sure what you're
you're talking about anymore and so
you might as well agree or or at least
you can agree and fit in
you know into the culture but there is a
there is a clerical class here
i wanted to make this this point that i
don't think most people actually
understand
um anything about these critical
theories and and it's very seductive for
a lot of people because i think there's
a real moral currency and
lure around oppression and victimhood
and these categories can even further
your career at work as well
and you know when you look at some of
these um critical theories that have
emerged from this and a lot of this
comes from reading pluck rose
you know things like disability studies
and critical race theory and third wave
feminism and queer theory and fat
studies and gender studies and
i think a lot of this actually came from
a really good place right because people
are genuinely concerned about um
stigmatization i mean there's the
the idea around um when homosexuality
for example it was actually
um seen as a as a kind of mental
pathology even by the who as recently as
the 1990s
and there's nothing wrong with
homosexuality so it's almost as if there
was this idea that
it's possible that science could be
completely wrong you know the medical
discourse has had this really oppressive
effect on on folks and and objective
truth
um can't be trusted anymore but the
problem is it's metastasized into all of
these weird places now so like
disability studies
you know where now for example a whole
identity has arisen around having a
disability or even being overweight
and you're not even supposed to aspire
to be healthy and to lose weight anymore
because you know there's nothing wrong
with being overweight
it's just very peculiar isn't it i mean
look all of these things have a point
right that's the the thing is that we
can we can all
get behind not you know not
discriminating against
someone who is different we can all get
behind
you know someone being in a minority and
having it actually harder
like in many in many minorities if you
are part of them you
actually have a harder life uh and
and the power the power behind the
messages i think that we all
recognize that this is true right and
this is a this is a very powerful thing
that
i think in combination with you know
changing up the words
of things um has a has a big effect so
maybe to to come back a bit to the
machine learning world
um i've i've had my own experiences with
kind of cancel cancel culture and and
all of this is
is kind of how so pedro maybe you can
you can sort of describe how does this
all
feed into your your experience with the
nurip's broader
impact statement what does it even have
to do like why did you even start
complaining about it let's say that
actually what's been happening with
europe
is actually a perfect illustration of
everything that we've been talking about
which again is like made for an
interesting i hope you call that article
you look at what's happening right with
this whole you know crowd of vocalism
and whatnot
and then you look at ai and then you do
the thought experiment
what is going to happen when these two
things collide right
and i was actually thinking about this
before the collision actually happened
so
and then the details are unpredictable
and often exceed what you were thinking
about
but the outlines of it are not
surprising
so you know like what's been happening
with europe's needs to be understood
in terms of how does ai play into what
this culture is trying to do
right and what's happening is that um
there are all these things that have
been put in place
uh you know in terms of for example uh
preferences
by you know by gender and by race and
more generally like enforcing equal
outcomes
for these different classes right you
know if there's x percent
men at the start they have to be at the
end and that's it
right and you know that's what they call
equity right and the problem is that
once a lot of the relevant decisions
started being made by algorithms
this is in danger because the whole
assumption in all this is that humans
are so biased so you have to overwrite
them with these laws right a lot of
these things are in law
right and again you know back to your
earlier point
a lot of these laws have reason to exist
because there was discrimination and
there is still some
but that movement largely succeeded and
and then what do you do right how do you
disband the army after it's won the war
it doesn't want to be disbanded he wants
to keep being you know conquering
and that's when the the meaning of the
terms start to change
and things that when racism were sexism
become racism and sexism
and and that's where you know that takes
us where we are today
now the problem with for example if i
use a classifier you know to decide
whether to
interview someone for a job or not is
that that classifier
as we all know is basically a complex
formula that was applied to some data
right like you know think of linear
regression right
is linear regression racist right
now anybody who knows math thinks like
that's just a completely ridiculous
thing to suggest right like
how can y equals ax plus b be racist
this is just like
you know how can you even you know take
that seriously
however right there is this whole field
that has grown up in a eye
of fairness in ai a large part of whose
agenda is that like no
these algorithms have biases and we are
going to remove them
can can i can i just frame this because
i think we don't need the machine
learning algorithms to understand this i
think let's just take a step back so
for example we were talking about
disability studies that the idea from
the social constructivist point of view
is that um there's a sense of fairness
that we all have and that's why so many
people can get on board with this
and we we don't want to have
discrimination and all of us it goes
about saying we are poor all forms of
racism and
misogyny and transphobia et cetera of
course we do so it all comes down to
this issue of fairness
and a social constructivist would say
that the society if it can afford to do
so
should remove all forms of
discrimination and unfairness so
um as a disabled person for example i
should be able to cross the road and i
shouldn't be impeded in doing so in any
way
so i think it all comes from a place
where
um we can't be trusted to make the right
decisions because there are so many
machine learning engineers out there
and they can't be trusted to ensure that
folks have a completely unimpeded
experience
and therefore we need to set up systems
or gateways
to make sure it happens the right way is
that is that roughly it well exactly but
then the question becomes
who mans those gateways right and to use
rips as an example there's been a whole
succession of ways by which this craft
has expressively
strangled europe's i would say and now
we're having to deal with it
but the most recent one on the one that
actually started this incident i was
involved in is that
the new ipswipers now are subject to
what's called an
ethics review and they have to have what
is called a brother
impact statement and there is this
sentence in the in the europe's gulf of
papers that i just find
delicious which says that irrespective
of the scientific merit
your paper may be rejected if it
promotes unfairness
right and now let us deconstruct this
right
uh you know appropriate worth here
right uh we all agree that
you know fairness is important right and
again part of why this crowd is able to
get the purchase that it does is that
they come at us with these words like
ethics and fairness that like they're
like motherhood and apple pie
who could disagree right i like when i
push back against the you know a lot of
the reactions like
what you're against ethics you must be a
criminal
but but what's going on and this of
course is under the cover of ethics all
we actually have
is politics and under the cover of
fairness what we actually have is an
agenda
to promote some groups at the expense of
others and now
right to make things better or worse
depending on how you look at it
you know every paper that i write in you
know from europe's a paper about you
know speeding upgrading descent
has to talk about its implications on
fairness and things like that
and if they don't like it they will
reject it
there is now like you know a police an
ethics police that says like
we know what's ethical and if we don't
like your paper you know your paper
gets rejected because it's not ethical
so can i can i challenge you a bit
though because
okay any tool any process can
can be abused like i i agree with you on
that which is that
if there's a board or a committee you
know and and the right or wrong people
are on there and or it's not transparent
enough which i think is
you know transparency is probably the
key importance but it can be abused okay
no doubt about that
however you know ethics review boards
are certainly nothing new
in other fields like you know medical
research or whatever it's been around
for
for quite a while so i'm wondering you
know if you think there's a role at all
for any kind of ethics review within the
machine learning and ai community and if
there
is how should these boards be structured
or improved
um you know to have limiting principles
if you will
to keep them from kind of going down a
slippery slope or being abused
very good question so i very much agree
that there's an important place for
ethics in ai right and
part of why i wrote the master algorithm
and i say that in the book right one of
my main motivations is that
everybody needs to be aware of the
issues so that they can make informed
decisions about it
because these ethical and political
decisions and so on
you know in a democracy they're supposed
to be made by everybody right
and now you say and this is this is the
example that people always bring up so
like oh but in medicine there are ethics
review boards
therefore there should be ethics or
reports in the ai this is a bad
inference
this is a bit like saying like you know
i need to cover my eyes from the sun
therefore i need to cover my eyes from
the candle the question that we need to
ask ourselves is like where in
ai does this need to happen right
i'm not saying that it just doesn't need
to happen anywhere
at all right i'm not saying that there's
no ethics of ai
of course there is right but now you
know
should there be an ethics review
of nipp's papers does every europe's
paper
need to have a section on broader
impacts i don't think so
and this is something that you can
debate right and we were actually
debating this for a few days before the
council
mob moved in and why they moved in i
think is is an interesting illustration
but i i think that a paper that is for
example about speeding upgrading descent
doesn't need to have a broader impact
section one point there like just
because it's a good example you know
speeding up gradient descent why would
that have any ethics and
implications let me just give you a
straw man or a
steel man you know for that for that
argument okay
for example and tim nick gabruz you know
paper the one that's
you know caused some controversy sort of
recently
one kind of point that they raised in
there which i personally agree with
is that as say deep neural networks
become yet larger and ever
billions of parameters or whatever they
become ever more
uh outside of the realm of human
kind of understanding of what's
happening inside that algorithm
and we know that you know if there are
things in the data that it can find that
are proxies for stuff like
race or you know ethnicity or whatever
it can find them things like zip code in
the united states for example
okay and so as the as they become more
and more complex they become less
amenable to our
oversight if you will and so speeding up
gradient descent
say if it enables us to go from 1
billion to
100 billion parameters actually can make
that problem worse right and so if i was
writing a paper and submitting that to
nurips i might put that in my broader
impact statement
i might say in fact this could allow
like ever larger models we need to
think very carefully about the increase
in complexity oversight isn't that fair
completely fair you can put that in your
paper
and some people will but there's two
important points here that like
that is not the question here the
question is should you be forced
to put that in the paper and right now
you are
right yeah that's what i'm against it's
like people can put whatever they want
in their papers and discussing the
social implications this is
great it's fine what i'm against is
having a requirement
that everybody has to discuss this and
the second point
is and then what happens with that the
other part is like
what what what what that gets used for
but the second
you know but but the other side of this
is the followings that like i am not
saying that gradient descent does not
have
social or ethical implications of course
it does and you just give an example
and there are many more what i'm what
i'm contesting is that
every paper that is written about
gradient descent needs to have a
discussion
of those ethic implications this is
ridiculous it's just like wasting
everybody's time
right i think i'm very much in favor of
scientists being aware of the social
implications of the work that they do i
myself have motivated not just by
the or in particular by the science
being interesting but by the
applications
right but everybody doesn't have to be
talking about it in every one of the
papers that they do the community as a
whole
needs to have an interface to society
and the community as a whole needs to be
dealing
with the social political ethical
implications of what it does the idea
that
you know every time that i write a paper
that shaves you know an order of and
of the speed of an algorithm i have to
talk about society and what this means
to me it's just ridiculous i can see
this both ways right so
um the nuclear scientists they they said
no because
because they they could clearly see that
the consequences of what they were doing
but i'm also skeptical whether you even
can see the consequences of what you do
that
i already think um even without the
broader impact statements there's so
much group thinking myopia in the
scientific community
you know that's why we're not really
exploring i mean kenneth stanley would
say that we're not we're not exploring
we're exploiting
but the broader impact statements in
practice they don't carry any
information at all
they just say technology good technology
bad technology bias they're completely
formulaic in their construction
sticking exercises you have to make this
design you have to make technology good
technology bad
technology biased i stole that from
culture but um
no but the thing is you know i i think
it stifles innovation but
and also um it clearly hasn't
demonstrated any effect whatsoever and
the folks that are on these boards
are of a certain political persuasion um
it would be different because i'm a big
fan
of having diversity of viewpoints i
think that
that can have an interesting effect in
terms of being able to see potential
consequences if that's even possible
but that's just not being proven out
with this at all no on the contrary what
this promotes is not diversity of
viewpoints it's funneling everything
into the viewpoint of these people who
at least some of them are quite explicit
that these are just tactics
to impose their view on us right there
was this workshop at
europe's right on broader impacts where
some of the people who crafted this
whole
you know thing were there including the
head of the ethics board and so on
and and one of them said like you know
we are doing these things because they
are the low hanging
fruit the review process is the review
low hanging fruit
for the agenda that we want to impose
there was no discussion in that whole
you know panel that i
that i that i saw of whether this is
good or bad
the only this question was of how so
there's two things right and on one hand
you can say
look what does it hurt what does it hurt
to make even to force
everyone to think about the the ethical
implications right what what is the
even you know we force someone it can't
hurt right but on
on the other hand a bit my question to
you is how much of
that and you already alluded to it is
not as much about ethics as it is about
politics and power because i've made a
video when they introduced this
requirement
and you could actually see the kind of
power struggle
in real time at first the
one of the representatives of nurips
gave an interview
and in the interview they said oh the
broader impact statement it will be in
the appendix and it will only be visible
i think after submission and so on and
then
in the next kind of iteration it was no
the broader impact statement
will be in the main part and it will be
visible
but you must not do any decision about
it and then in the next iteration it was
oh now you can get
rejected because of it but if your work
is very theoretical
you can say this doesn't apply to us but
then
they also they link to like blog posts
so it's not official communication but
they
officially link to them and these blog
posts essentially say
you might want to put a lot of work into
it even if your work is theoretical
because
if you don't then we're just sort of
going to assume that the rest of the
paper
is also has also been done with not
enough care and not enough
uh not enough kind of sloppy as you did
the broader impact statement so you
could see
in real time like how how this
got up and up and up and and that makes
me kind of doubt that it is
it that it is about ethics and uh i have
my troubles right
even though the motivation is even the
forcing
can be like what does it hurt to make
everyone think about the broader impact
and there's two answers to that question
the first
which is actually the less important one
is that even if you take it at face
value if you shouldn't it does hurt
because you know me spending a few hours
writing a broader impact statement is
not a big deal but 10
000 people times that number of hours is
a big deal
number one right but that's so that
enough is reason
not to have you know ethics statements
for most newspapers
right particularly the ones that are not
about a specific application but that
are about general techniques like you
know
speeding upgrading to center or whatever
but that's actually the least important
part of this in fact
when we have this discussion we're
actually playing their game
because we're confusing the the
camouflage for the real thing
right so like oh there's nothing wrong
with this brother impact segments
because you know everybody cares about
pride impact segments
these things are a cover for an agenda
to impose a play a particular set of
views
and again you just you know showed step
by step what happens
and you know one of the pushbacks that i
got white was
oh from from raya hetzel i think you
know not just anybody
uh um you know a co-chair uh of of
europe's this year was
oh but we only rejected four papers
so who should worry about four papers
being rejected right who cares it's no
big deal
right yeah in my mind what it reminded
me of was like when the taliban you know
conquered one town after another in
afghanistan
one of one of the you know key pieces of
their mo was they hung a few
people it didn't even matter who was
being hung they just hung them in the
public square
right and you could say like but we only
hung two people in a town of ten
thousand what is the problem
that's how everybody else gets control
and this is exactly the process by which
that happens
and we have to see through it well but
it's great to see through that okay but
on the other hand
just because somebody has an agenda
doesn't mean that all the things that
they suggest
are necessarily bad ideas right i mean
in other words a lot of what needs to
move forward in terms of public
public good society processes whatever
has to be had through compromise
so it's like okay people with agenda a
are sitting over there and agenda b are
on the other side of the table and c
is somewhere in between and we got to
come together and hash out and discuss
these and a lot of what you're pointing
out
there are slippery slopes for sure and
so we have to hash out what those
limiting principles are and making sure
that we develop a process
you know that that incorporates your
objections it incorporates the
objections of
you know whatever other people with
agendas don't we i think it's the
application of technology
uh you know where you actually have the
real impact but i want to try and steel
man this a little bit so um kate
crawford did a
presentation at europe's i think in
about 2018 and she was speaking about
some of the harms of biased
algorithms i mean you can think of some
bad examples like the chinese
criminality detection using physionomy
and phrenology and
the social credit score system in china
and you know
basically her thesis by the way was that
we need to have
some kind of a trustworthy class of
people who understand
all of these um power structures in
society and the implication is that ml
engineers don't get it they have to be
social scientists and
you know even if they're not social
scientists have to be something else but
but you know you can go through all of
the different harms right so it's things
like
the classification of people you're
putting people into buckets in 2016
there were already 16 genders on
facebook and i'm sure it's
increased dramatically since then harms
of representation so you know selection
bias or racial stereotyping
resource or allotment allocation so who
gets mortgages
under representation so you know we
think of ceos as being white people
or denigration so if you type in into
gbt3 if you say a muslim walks into a
store and let it complete i mean you
know you can guess what it will say
and things like measurement and proxy
bias and she
even provides some potential solutions
so things like neutralizing the data
or equal representation or awareness or
fairness forensics and
you know let's get into this discussion
of what is fairness
should we de-bias these data sets and
what would that look like
well exactly so um the problem with this
whole agenda of devicing the data sets
is well actually it's more than one
problem but the first and most important
problem that i have with this
is that to me and maybe i'm just a naive
machine learning
engineer the purpose of a model is to
reflect the world as accurately as
possible
and then based on that accurate
perception of reality we can make
whatever decisions we want
we can have a process that uses the
machine learning album that has whatever
objective function we design
right and that's where the social debate
needs to come in
not in the optimization and
representation part those are
essentially technical problems
right we can then decide what the goals
are but a lot of the agenda here is like
this it's it's really blaming the
messenger it says like oh
there's bigoted pages on on on the web
and you're not allowed to learn from
them
or an even better example that i just
find delicious is the whole thing about
embeddings and and whatnot that's
like oh embeddings are so biased because
what
because they find that there's a greater
correlation between man and programmer
than between women and program right
you've probably seen all these examples
right they associate men with
programmers and women with some you know
teacher something that will
mark and do and then they want to devise
the data set
because this is wrong but the thing is i
want to still man their argument here
because
if you did believe that there was a
patriarchy and there was a white
supremacist force in society and so on
you i can understand their thought
process they think that the only reason
we don't have more women software
engineers is because
of all this male toxicity and patriarchy
and it's it's not
it's not an encouraging place for them
to come and work so we need to we need
to tweak a few knobs and levers to
to balance it out so what do you think
about that oh i completely understand
their thought process but you know just
to do the if then statement right
if even if that was what i believed
right i would not advocate that the way
to do this is to change the data
this is a little paradoxical right
there's a problem
that there aren't enough female
programmers let's say that that is a
problem
right then what do you do you erase the
data that says there's a problem
right this will be likes and like what
i'm going to do is replace the world
that i want with the
the world that i have with the fantasy
one that i want and that is the right
thing to do
right but that would that would work
though that's what they want to do so
they want us to preferentially
let's say hire more female software
engineers and and it would
it would do that so it wouldn't even
work like i mean and again i understand
the frame of mind right and like so
let me sort of like try to state that
side of things for just a second and
again
as in all of these things going back to
post-modernism it actually starts with
the kernel of truth
right and the kernel of truth here is
that perception
is important to reality right if women
see
that all programmers are male they will
not be interested in going into computer
science right
and therefore how do we fight that we
change the perception
right and and you know and i think there
are some aspects of that that are
you know you know acceptable like for
example you know hollywood movies these
days they often have you know
uh female judges or black ceos right
because
you know like that just plants in your
mind that they don't have to be white
men
right but now you have first of all you
have to balance the good that does
against the harm and you know a
hollywood movie is a hollywood movie
right that's one thing right another
thing is that
and in some ways this is the most
important one and we've seen this at
work in the last few decades is that
people aren't stupid and sooner or later
they perceive that they're being duped
and then they become even more skeptical
but this is this is the perverse thing
about is like oh but you know
women and men don't go into programming
you know at equal rights you've been
lying to me i don't believe your crap
i don't believe the experts anymore
right and this is though
this is not what you see what's
happening is like people are completely
skeptical of us the experts
because they realize that we've been
politicized and moreover
you know when you do this right then you
say like oh you know like we just hired
this woman then then
perversely what this does is it
justifies the sexism it says like oh you
hired her because
right so even on the terms of what this
crowd wants
ultimately these things are
counterproductive i think i feel there
are two things
at work you said i want a model that
reflects
the world as as accurately as it is
and there are actually problems with the
models that we have so for example
very often our data sets they aren't the
world they're like a collection of the
world
since 1950 and you know we're sort of
telling the model look this is all
equally valid which it is not
and then there are other problems for
example
machine learning models necessarily or
sometimes need to
kind of compress the data and so
a good way to reduce your loss function
is actually to just
memorize the majority and just forget
the minority right
so you can you can make a good case that
you know machine learning models even in
their essence uh
have an effect of actually not
representing the world but
to introduce their own biases and i can
i can completely understand
this you know people saying this and
saying look we need to
we need to do something about that but
then on the other hand
i also feel as i said there's two
effects at work
two things can be true at the same time
these models do have their problems but
also
uh there is a completely different thing
when you say i don't like
the world as it is i'm gonna make my
model
say something else because i want to
have a certain effect
and these things they get mixed up and i
i don't
i don't i don't like that and i often
feel they deliberately get mixed up
in that it justifying the second thing
by quoting the first thing
well models uh have lots of problems of
course that's why we machine learning
researchers their jobs
right but you have it's important to
understand what the problems are and
what the valid solutions are right so
the first problem is the data right we
have this beautiful fiction
in statistics and machine learning of
the iid data set
right there is no such thing right back
in the days of ronald fisher when you
could spend a lot of time assembling it
that is set of you know
you know a design matrix right notice
the word design there right
you could try to really make sure that
this was a representative sample of the
world
and we all know that this is not a new
problem right you know your sample
should be representative of the world if
the data isn't represented the world you
learn a bad model right this is nothing
to do with fairness this is just a
you know it's it's not something that
affects you know gender or race or
whatever specific this is just doing
good machine learning
right and and we always need to be
fighting that battle both as researchers
and as their scientists but at the same
time right
there's something important that you
have to realize which is uh it's a
battle that cannot be won
and if we insisted on doing machine
learning with all the beautiful and
great and you know lot
you know laudable guidelines that we
have from statistical theory
we wouldn't have machine learning today
all of these goods that machine learning
does
wouldn't be there because it would still
be in the lab figuring out how would
how we're going to make this data set
more perfect right so this
is not realistic again it's not a reason
for giving up right it is our job
to try to make the data as clean as
representative as possible but
you know the bigger the data set and
therefore more powerful the less of this
is going to is going to be possible
right and that's my reason to stop and
moreover
again the agenda of these people is not
dealing with this in general is to focus
on some variables to the expense of
others
and i have a big problem with that
because the whole point of machine
learning
is that it allows personalization it
allows you know
catering to the individual as opposed to
putting them in a few boxes
oh you're a white male and therefore
this is what happens to you right so so
doing that is is the negation
of machine learning in my view let's
take a just a super simple example that
i hope we can all agree
uh if i'm building a hand wash dispenser
that you know people stick their hands
under it and it uses whatever some kind
of machine learning algorithm
on light sensors to decide that it's
actually a human hand and it should
dispense
a certain quantity of soap i'm assuming
we all agree that that should
work equally well for all skin colors
right
um no actually um that it you're right
this is a great example because it's so
simple
right and and um but it worries me
right precisely because of what i just
said why
so actually the way to do this right is
this is
the following like i'm going to design
you know
a subdispenser i have a sensor right
what is my objective function right it
doesn't have anything to do with skin
color
it's that you know let's say that we are
egalitarian i am
right you know ideally it should work
equally well for all people
ideally right but once that you know but
if it doesn't
right then what i have to do is make it
the best possible even if i sacrifice
some things for the sake of others right
because
some of those trade-offs are inevitable
right
and the example that you're posing is
like why are we favoring skin color over
everything else
what is special about skin color i would
actually argue that that
is a racist point of view to say i'm
going to
worry about skin color when when when
working on a soap dispenser as opposed
to treating everybody equally
right and again to pursue that example a
little a little further
some skin colors might be harder to
detect than others
that's right in particular facial
recognition is harder when you have less
contrast etcetera etcetera right
but that's the point that we can debate
what is the best way to deal with this
but it is
absolutely not a given that we should
just aim
for skin colors to be you know uh equal
for the for the detector to be equally
good
at two different skin colors maybe
that's what we want maybe that's not but
that is not an assumption that we should
start from well i can tell you in the
united states that's an assumption you
should start from
because it's a legal requirement that it
treats all people equally regardless of
of skin color right and so but if we
could just pause it let's just suppose
that is a requirement
that that when people put their hands
under there it has to perform equally
well regardless of their
their skin tone okay how do you suggest
that we go about and and let's imagine
the data sample is skewed right like
because only 13 of the population is
is black and 50 percent is white or
whatever
so we have a skewed data sample right
how do we go about
making sure that our end product works
equally well for all skin tones
so but what you're saying that the law
in the united states requires that soap
dispensers work equally well for
different skin colors
yes i am here is where you actually can
make the case
for something like a broader impact
statement because
it is not this the dispenser because the
dispenser has downstream effects
if some people you know in the extreme
can't wash their hands as well
they lose more time they are more uh
they are more prone to infections
because the soap dispenser didn't work
there are all these downstream effects
that this can have and you you you know
being a
being the the capitalists that we are we
are just going to worry
like where do we put more effort we're
going to put more effort into
selling more to the to the majority and
not
to the minorities and this kind of
triggers a
feedback loop and so on so there is a a
good case to be
to be made for kind of the laws that
keith you know mentioned yeah could i
just touch on on the feedback loop thing
because
there is a kind of patriarchal aspect
here that
um i think these these people want to
protect us from ourselves
it's one of the reasons why the social
dilemma film was quite fascinating
because um it creates this very strange
um behavior this emergent behavior where
it deranges our attention and
all of these weird addictive behaviors
emerge out of nowhere
and it's a similar thing with with ai
systems right even if you had a system
that
perfectly modeled reality as it is now
it would still i mean from a progressive
point of view this is your worst
nightmare because it's gonna
it's gonna stagnate society it's gonna
stop society from moving where we want
to go i mean okay so let's let's take
this one part at a time right
we can ask so i again i'm curious
exactly what law says skin dispensers
sorry soft dispensers have to be skin
invariant but let's assume that that law
exists well
there's the first part is that that law
is wrong
right but let's table that right and we
can discuss why you know why i think
it's wrong right
but let's let's let's ignore that it's
wrong and just take it as a given
another now your question i assume is
like so what do we do about this that's
right
well uh we we can actually do what
people do which is we can have it you
know as a constraint
in our whole system not the learned
model in the end system
that you know the outcome has to be xyz
right and
and and we can discuss what their
outcomes should be but again
the problem with a lot of what's
happening is that it's not about
fostering a discussion about the outcome
should be that's like
this is the outcome that we want and if
you either and you either hue to it
or you get silence your paper gets
rejected whatever right so another cover
very postmodernly under the cover of
let's have discussion
what this thing is doing is preventing
discussion right but now there's another
problem with these issues that like
these requirements aren't even
self-consistent right
if you take the sum total of the legal
requirements so let's take more
important things like you know job
you know applications and and you know
policing and whatnot
these things are mutually contradictory
you can actually not even have them all
at the same time
so if we as engineers say like oh yeah
i'm just going to obey all of these laws
it's physically impossible maximize at
the same time
because they're dependent so you're in
the position which is very well known of
people in like you know communist
countries about that like
we are all sinners no matter whatever
what you do you you're doing it wrong
no i i understand i understand the point
you're making but i'm still so
look all tools can be abused again right
and and for example
fairness i mean i've been in multiple
fairness discussions right and every
time i ask
what is the state of the art for the
definition of fairness i never really
get
a good example for example we once
discussed the allotment thing well you
know if uh
more than pro-rata of mortgages are
going to this group then it's then it's
not fair and i said okay so let me just
ask the question
if i build a neural network that allots
of mammograms to women is that fair
and that usually throws a wrench kind of
in their whole process because we know
that 99
of breast cancer cases you know occur in
biological
you know xx individuals and therefore we
should a lot more mammograms to them and
so
you know on the one hand i think there
should be a very public and transparent
conversation and maybe one day actually
a database that says
these factors you can use for x purpose
but you can't use them
for this purpose and so for example skin
color i don't think skin color
should affect whether or not you get
soap when you put your hand under a
dispenser
i do think gender should affect whether
or not you're
allocated a mammogram i do think race
can actually
impact medical suggestions like you said
you know there are racial
uh variabilities right and your
susceptibility to different diseases and
we want to account for all of that
so the right solution isn't just to
ignore these factors
it's to have a very transparent
conversation about
which are usable for what purpose
but once we come to that conclusion
we've got to have a tool set
to actually do that and i'm asking you
like what tool set do you think
should be used to achieve for example
equal dispensing of soap
just before we get to that can i just
test a couple of principles
that there are lots of things that we
decide as a society are fair or moral
and we change our mind progressively
over time
and even things like you know we wear
seat belts at some point we didn't need
to wear seat belts and
at the time everyone decried wearing
seat belts and now we would never turn
the clock back
you know and there must be lots of
things that we agree on here just
you know on our moral compass i mean we
shouldn't discriminate against
homosexual people for example
what if it were the case that um
there was lots of latent discrimination
against homosexual people
and we thought that they were not
competent programmers so because of that
um lasting prejudice we didn't hire any
gay people and all of our models have
learned not to hire gay people and we
know for sure that that's a ridiculous
rule
the model shouldn't have learned that
rule um what do we do then
is that something we should neutralize
very good example and and very good
points right and i think you know
you know keith you're saying like we
need to have a conversation about which
variables we use when and how
right so let's have that conversation
right and here's what i think should be
done
right it's actually very simple right is
when you're learning a model to predict
something right
all variables are fair game in fact
you're not doing the rational thing if
you do not use all the relevant
information
and you're not a good page and if that's
your persuasion right vaginism says you
have to use all the available evidence
we're doing the wrong thing
right therefore variables like
race gender sexual orientation should be
a priori
allowed for whatever decision you want
to make
because they might be relevant whether
or not they're relevant
is a matter of is it's not a matter of
art
the problem that i have with a lot of
this is that the art is infecting the is
and but let me finish they should be
used
on equal terms with the other variables
i shouldn't say
so like there's this schizophrenic thing
of like i either can't use those
variables
or i'm forced to use them over and above
all others and both of these things are
wrong
learn your model and those variables
will have whatever you know
place they have right now to go back to
the homosexual program as the example
right let's say you know i'm google and
i'm writing a program to
rate people as to how likely they are to
be good programmers right and one of the
available variables
is there's sexual orientation right now
there's two parts to this at least one
of them is if their sexual orientation
truly is irrelevant to their skills
programmers that variable will not be in
the model and the problem is solved
right another possibility is that
homosexuality really is relevant to
being a good programmer maybe
gay people are better programmers in
which case they should be favored
to the extent that that favors them
right so that's that's the other aspect
but then there's a very important one
which again keeps coming up in all this
which is like
but what if the data that i'm learning
from was the decisions of previous
hiring committees
and they were biased against gay people
and therefore they show up as not being
good programmers
and i that is a real problem right but
it's a data quality problem that we've
already talked about
right the problem is the problem there
is that i'm learning from bad data
therefore i'm learning a bad model
so what you do there you know let's
let's pick a better example which is
credit assignment and a very salient one
there are laws about this and redlining
and whatnot right is
you know like what am i making
when i'm learning you know and i've you
know i've i've used you know data sets
like this right
the data sets have created decisions are
is the class variable something that was
produced by a biased human labeler in
which case there's something to worry
about
or what is or was it the outcome
right the outcome is this person paid
their loan or this person did not pay
their loan and these are completely
different things
the outcome is the outcome right and now
now you could say oh but they didn't pay
their loan because they were you know
there were risk vices against them on
one and not like maybe but that's your
hypothesis now
right and if my goal is simply to you
know like not go out of business and
make
you know good loans and so forth i'm
actually authorized to use
those decisions but it's very different
right whether
whether the label was produced by a
human versus where the label is an
outcome of the real world
actually when i want to go go back a
little bit uh coming back to this the
the kind of nurip's discussion now
you've you've started talking about how
you know what what issue you had with
broader impact statements and then
this whole thing happened to you right
and um
the article you wrote is i i like a lot
of it and you give some recommendations
of
what to do uh when something like this
happens to you and as i said having
experienced a much smaller scale of this
but
but it can definitely relate uh
things like yeah pick your battles know
what to expect don't back down so
i encourage anyone to actually read this
article
um though i do have so you have one
one suggestion in there which is turn
their weapons
against them and uh
i just wanna maybe if you allow me just
read this
here you say you may find this to be the
most controversial principle
and yes i do but it is also arguably
the most crucial as the counselors won't
stop until they fear that they'll endure
the same consequences that they
seek to impose on others in my case
i watched as investors and customers
leaned on the ringleaders company to
rein them in even companies that posture
heavily in the area of social justice
don't actually want to be stained by the
disgraceful
behavior of mob leaders indeed i have no
doubt that it was an
ultimatum from or that person's employer
that finally led
to her to stop twitter and so on so you
say and you you say at the end
some will say that once we resort to
this step
we become as bad as the cancelers but
that's a false equivalence
the cancel crowd tries to ban people
because of their views
we try to stop bullying behavior that
is reprehensible regardless of ideology
so my so this is something i
i i don't i don't agree with on like
i even even if i think someone is a
bully and so on i
would not go to their employer and and
be like look look look look because
that's
like i feel if you if you go to
someone's employer
uh you're like take a look at yourself
like that's
that's a that's a place where i don't go
and because
you know these the people they would
claim
you're the bully and therefore they have
every right to go to your employer
right they would claim they have every
right to go dig up dirt on you because
all they want to do is stop your
bullying right and you do
your your twitter presence is is
not you know not the most nuanced if i
can if i can be honest you voice your
opinions and
i feel sometimes you do it also a little
bit
to get a a reaction and you're i mean
you're
not by far not you know at the end of
the spectrum
in even in this debate there has been
multiple people i think one of them is
now suspended that clearly are
only there to incite
to inflame tensions they they go in
and they get a little bit offended like
i'll sue you i'll sue you and so there
there is this
you know behavior and why aren't you the
bully
like what what right do
like how can you say we should stop them
with their methods because they're the
bullies
how does this not apply to you can i
just quickly add on to that as well
because
there is an element of you fighting fire
with fire and
i must admit one of the things i want to
explore with you is is it the substrate
of twitter
because i think i think many people
involved in this in this discussion are
good people
and twitter has brought the worst out in
you and i i
i think the way you behaved on twitter
does slightly discredit your your
argument pedro just being honest i i
think that
you've gone over a line that i wouldn't
go over and why did that happen
well to answer your question first i
don't think i've gone over any lines
obviously
i'm not on twitter to get a rise out of
anybody i'm just presenting my
my views it is true that very much so
let's be very clear about that and even
some of the people that you would say
were only you know young that yannick
that you said were only that being 20
people they weren't
because i've actually talked with them
and you know they i don't necessarily
agree with what they did but you know
they
i agree with our motivations and and
with a lot of what they said
um but you know to uh to get to the main
point here
this is really i mean i think this is
crucial again of everything in that
article this is this is indeed the most
important point
and and and and because this is why
we're losing this war
it's because you know the other side has
guns and we think guns are immoral
so we let them shoot us so we have we
have to and like and
we really need i think and i mean i've
had discussions with a lot of people
about this and i understand why this is
a tricky point
which is why we need to address it
head-on i think first of all we need to
distinguish
the ends and the means right the
the cancel crowd's goal is to is to
silence people who express their views
my goal is to let everyone express their
views
i believe that my goal is a good one and
their goal is a bad one
so the first way in which we're
different is that we differ on goals
they're using these tools these weapons
for bad goals
and we're using them for good goals
again just because
you know to bring up the nazis had guns
doesn't mean that the allies
want to have guns right because if the
ls didn't have tanks and airplanes the
war would have been lost so
this is the first important thing to
realize right but the second one which i
think confuses people even more
is the following is that i'm not saying
that the full range of weapons
is okay absolutely not so what things
are okay versus aren't and again
i say that in other parts of the article
insulting people is never okay
taunting people is never okay telling
lies
is not okay etc etc so there's a whole
bunch of things that i do not condone
and i have said that i do not condone
right
but now let's talk about specifically
about things like leaning on employees
on employers or boycotting organizations
that do the wrong thing
is that fair game it absolutely is fair
game
all sorts of great things have been
accomplished by doing that right
you know boycotting south africa helped
the end apartheid
and you know it's like there was a
debate you know are we making the you
know the
are we making people suffer for nothing
right but i think
as a principal in general you know
leaning on organization
look i'm a customer of you know a lot of
companies
you know i'm totally free to say like
i'm not going gonna buy a product
because i don't like what you do
so when the works do that you know i may
disagree with the reason they're doing
it but i'm not saying they don't have a
right to
right yeah but but you're you're i mean
it's it's a different
it's a different thing um
because very often that's not what's
going on right when people
for example contacted my employer i had
i had some people say what we're we're
not we're not canceling you we're just
expressing our opinion into the
direction
of your employer and and basically
saying that well it is perfectly okay to
inform your employer
of what you're doing and if if they
decide that's reprehensible
then they have every right to let you go
which is
true however what often the goal
of something like this is is that you
simply make it a pr
problem for the employer you simply you
simply
you you know you write an email i'm very
concerned that
this behavior and so on and you're
counting on the fact that your employer
doesn't have a lot of time doesn't have
a lot of insight into the matter
simply sees the word like a bunch of bad
words associated with an employee
and then does something to kind of make
its public image
look good and this is to me like i'm
i really disagree with this fighting
fire by fire because you legitimize
the the tactics of those people i
i understand right again i've i have
felt that as well
right so i've been the target of that
right one of the first things they did
was target my university
and every other organization that i'm a
part of and here's the thing
they already use that tool extensively
against us
why can we not use it against them it's
unilateral disarmament
right what the employer should do in
that case they're like look you know go
away
right and often they don't right
precisely because of these problems but
and and the problem is that as a tool
this is extremely effective in fact
you know people insulting you on twitter
well big deal right that happens every
day
losing a job well that really is a big
deal right
if we allow them to use that against us
and we don't use it against them we are
doomed
right you gotta fight fire with fire
right
i disagree so um that's that's just
because
because you legitimize it right because
they say look your behavior on twitter
makes the space unsafe some people feel
you know they feel unsafe therefore
you're the bully
therefore and since you even admit you
would use those tactics
why can't they use the tactics again
there's a very very important distinct
another extremely important distinction
to be made here
is degree right these things even at
this level are not equivalent because
this canceled crowd goes to my employer
for pushing back against neuroscientific
statements
yes i mean let me make this point in
more abstract terms right
we should not ask a binary question is
it ever okay
to complain to your employer right that
is too crude
the question that we should ask which
includes that one as a special case is
like
what is the behavior what are the
actions that merit complaining to your
employer
and i believe the threshold for that
should be high
you don't go to your employer for
whatever somebody said on twitter
right that's just like not the point
right but there is a level beyond which
actually it is true that your employee
has reason to be concerned with how the
behavior the person will reflect badly
on them
so part of the problem with this crowd
is that they have the threshold in the
wrong place
just like what you do right so i think
there's these distinctions that we have
to make
about what is acceptable and what's not
and i think yannick that's that's kind
of um
you know a key differentiator here is
that
pedro does have limits i mean he you
know he pointed out
some limits beyond which he wouldn't go
and you know there's a matter of degree
here
and i think a big problem right now
would kind of allow the cancel culture
crowd
is they actually haven't even defined
any limits for themselves it's like even
your children
aren't off limits you know they would
send tweets and emails to your kids
schools that they if they knew how and
you know
say that they should be booted out of
the school because of the sins of the
father and you know
things like that i think if they if they
want to be let me give them some advice
out there i think in the long term if
they want to be more
successful in achieving some of their
agenda points that maybe a lot of other
people
might agree with like equal dispensing
of soap or something like that
you know that they they should learn
where their limits are and they should
adopt some limiting principles it's like
okay
should nips have been renamed to neurops
well
maybe there's some criteria there like
what should we base it
on like the percentage of attendees that
are upset or should we base it on
the size of their twitter following uh
if it's offensive
in in one language is that enough what
if it's a minor world dialect
you know i mean we need some like kind
of limiting principles so that we're not
just
like going around in circles kind of
rename everything to a numerical value
or something yeah the the problem with
that though is we're getting into the
whole discussion about safe spaces and
and fragility
and you know it's impossible now to have
a conversation without offending at
least one person well i think
we're going we're going into the
direction of now we have to decide
orbiters of these of these thresholds
right we we have to
and this is i mean of course thresholds
like this exist and society as a whole
has to find limits i'm just saying we
can raise the threshold
by not using kind of these tactics and
these tactics
ultimately they are made to distract
from the actual issues like if your
first reaction to someone disagreeing
with you is
this person is making an unsafe space
i'm going to dig up dirt on them
so i can kind of circumvent the argument
that
that's almost like an admission that
you're not in it for the argument i
think i think
what we should do is in all of these
things bring it back to the argument
like bring it relentlessly
bring it back be like what you know no
one cares who you are
no one cares who you work for right
you're saying something
and even though you might make the
argument they're
they're kind of not serious like they
you know follow a hidden agenda or
whatnot even then
we bring it back to the argument and we
we're just
showing that look we can discuss on what
you're saying i don't care who you are
and i i think that's the way to go
honestly i think pedro actually made a
very similar point in his in his list of
tactics
bringing it back to the key point don't
descend into the same kind of thing that
they do
i think that's absolutely essential
another thing that i think is essential
is a very simple principle is
everyone needs to grow a thicker skin
and i have a thick skin which i think is
good everybody needs to have a thick
skin
unfortunately what happens right now is
that being offended is rewarded
right i believe in the economists on the
north and that it's all about incentives
right right now you have an incentive to
be offended being offended is power
if i'm a victim i'm powerful i get to
impose what i want
by calling myself a victim so
everybody's con here's the big
victim and this is what tries
intersectionality right
intersectionality is purely like oh
i have more victim points than you and
there's a scramble
right for that right and what we have to
realize is like no this is what's wrong
right like you know victim points should
not exist
right so when we stop rewarding these
behaviors
they will stop happening and as long as
we reward them they will continue to
grow
i don't know i i agree with that and
i've even had experience in the
corporate world where i've seen the
inversion of power
where you can claim to be offended or
you know someone's appropriated your
culture or someone's
discriminated against you and and you
know very very senior managers can can
get fired because of it because we take
it so seriously anyway look we've only
got about 15 minutes left and i really
want to move the conversation over to
your
colonel paper so um you've recently
released a paper called deep
uh networks our kernel machines and why
this is fascinating remember in your
book you actually said that the
the analogizers and the connectionists
were in two different camps i don't know
whether this changes that but
you know the fascinating thing is that
the way that we pitch neural networks
it's always been the big sales pitch
that we can learn
representations as part of the training
process and all this magic stuff going
is going on and you apparently seem to
have demonstrated in in some sense that
you know um a trained neural network has
an equivalent kernel and a colonel is
quite literally a kind of superposition
of the training example so
can you unpack this for us yeah so um i
think starting from the master album is
actually perfect because
there are these five tribes the five
different paradigms and what i argue in
the book and that's why it's called the
master algorithm
is that what we really need at the end
of this to unify all of them into a
single one
that can do what each one of them can
right each one of them is addressing the
real problem
but sometimes people in that camp are
the under the illusion that that's the
only problem
when in fact we have to solve all of
them right and this paper is very much
a piece in that puzzle what this paper
does is that it shows that
in reality deep networks are just kernel
machines
so the connection is starting soon by
the analogizers which they might
might or might not like but but they are
and in fact not just
kernel machines but the paper is
actually it says that
all models learn by grading the center
kernel machines
and that encompasses a very large chunk
of machine learning including for
example things like graphical models
so you know because of this paper you
know a vision network is actually curled
into the estimation
right so i think this you know it's one
theorem right but i think it has a lot
of consequences one of which is that i
think
it really moves us forward in being able
to unify these different paradigms
right but also i think you know just to
get back to this
point which is what people usually focus
on most with this paper of
representation learning
right you're right the selling point for
me and for everybody else
of deep learning in fact i think it
should be called representation learning
and that's why iclear is called
international conference on learning
representations
because that is the whole idea right and
in fact i think there's probably no more
important problem in ai than
than how to learn representations right
the thing about deep learning as we have
it today is that i've always been a
little skeptical that the problem has
been solved i don't think it has
right and part of my skepticism comes
from the fact that like
really you think gradient descent can
learn representations
how exactly does that happen right and
then the problem is like again i mean
like you know i've been accompanying
this for decades i was doing deep
learning before it was cool and why not
it's like
there are these fuzzy intuitions about
the representation learning
but they never materialize into anything
concrete so i wanted to
understand just what exactly is going on
here right
and i think you know like the the the
papers you know simple as it is
is a step forward in this because like
what what we now can understand is that
what is going on in that big
impenetrable mass of weights
right that big mystery that you know is
bad for transparency is bad for
accountability
is bad for explainability right is bad
for you know moving the technology
forward
right that that big mess of weight is
actually only apparent
what is going on in that big mess of
weights is that the network has just
memorized all the examples
but instead of memorizing them
separately as you're doing a kernel
machine
right you know i really have a database
of all the examples it has superimposed
them all into the weights
right and honestly this was an
accidental idea but it's one of
the most brilliant ideas in the history
of machine learning
right think about it from the point of
view of kernel machines right
the the whole quadratic cost of
computing the gram matrix goes away
the whole problem that i have to run
through the examples of runtime
and the memory cost and the time cost
all of that goes away the examples are
just superimposed in the weights right
this is absolutely brilliant right
and also if you look at this from the
point of view of the brain which after
all is one is price connectionism right
and neuroscience and psychology
this is also a brilliant idea right like
that evolution had
right and now we like if you read some
of the neuroscience as i often do
because you know like i think you can
take ideas from it what strikes you is
that like it's
so hard to parse what the brain is doing
in terms of the concepts that we have
because these things all seem to be
being done by all parts at the same time
right it's not like oh there's this part
that does this function you know like in
vision
you know this thing is doing shape and
this thing is doing this after checking
like
everything seems to be being done you
know all over right
now we can look at this and go like oh
i'm going to decompose what's going
on here into all these components and
they're all on top of each other
right now i can look at a brain or
transform and say like
this is what it's really going on there
right computationally right
it would be ridiculous to actually
separate all these things
right but in terms of understanding what
is happening absolutely that's you know
that's
that's what you need to do what i love
about the paper is actually the fact
that
the path of training is contained in the
so you construct this kernel
um to make to make your case and the
path
of training of the weights from the
beginning to the optimum
is part of that kernel and i wanted to
to ask you this because nowadays we
often see models that
train to zero loss especially these
large language models
they train and train and train and at
some point they get to zero training
loss
so why the models generalize
is kind of a mystery right because they
can't just interpolate the training data
however do you think the fact that
you've shown that kind of the path of
training is
embedded into the weights does is that
maybe a clue
as to why these models generalize even
though they have zero training error
of course and again i think in some ways
people have been focusing on the wrong
thing they're like oh this thing
memorizes it and still generalizes well
that's not a puzzle we've always known
that you can memorize the data
and then generalize very well or very
poorly right memorizing that is not an
achievement
maybe for a neural network once upon a
time it was but but it's not right
it's called the database right to
memorize the data you don't even need to
learn
the whole question is like what do you
do on the points that are not in the
data
and you can't answer that question just
by looking at like did you memorize the
data right because
what matters is what happens elsewhere
right and now i think the construction
of the of the path kernel actually
does help with that right and it helps
with that in a number of ways first of
all
so the path so the path kernel is is
computed as an integral
over the path that the weights take
during training right
and one of the most important parts of
that path
is the beginning right one of the things
that this really i think brings to the
fore is the extreme importance of the
starting point
your initial random network is
is is is half the battle
right with the random weights and its
architecture in fact the architecture is
where you've put all your knowledge
and in fact is where people you know
like there's this
rhetoric i don't mean that in a bad
sense of rhetoric you know with deep
learning that like
oh you know we don't need knowledge
right that's the beautiful thing about
it no more future engineering
right isn't that great but this is not
true right
where have people spent all their time
in the last 10 years it's in engineering
the architecture
right and then and then you pick these
random weights right but in fact what
you do is you don't pick one set of
random weights you pick a whole bunch of
them right and then you average
which means right if you look at this
from a beijing point of view you're just
averaging over your model class
right so this all makes perfect sense
right like most of what happens
is determined by the initial network and
then you can get it to converge to fit
the training data but in terms of
generalization
the initial network is as important as
the convergence that you have at the end
of the day
number one let me what happens over the
path right this is actually the thing
that's very interesting
right and this is really the core of of
the theory right
is that grading this what is greatest in
doing like it's moving
you know your weights right to make the
network do better on the training
examples
right and the thing that i'm doing in
this paper is essentially just running
this very simple mental experiment is it
like
if i not take my test point right
and just run the test point through the
exact same process that the training
points ran through
except it's not allowed to influence it
of course because it was in the path
in the past right but i just run the
training point through that what happens
and now suddenly i think things become
very clear because what happens is
the the network you know suppose for
example that i'm just learning you know
incrementally with one example at a time
right the
the weights are going to be adjusted to
better fit the value for that function
of the function for that point what does
that do on the test point
if the gradient for the test point lines
up well with the gradient for that
training point
it will be affected similarly if it's
orthogonal it won't be affected at all
right so in the end the effect of the
training on the test point
is a function of how similar that test
point was to each of the training
examples
along the path so the path really is the
whole thing
you were emphasizing the importance of
the starting point but i think
that also indicates to me that there's
just
tons of symmetries that we're not
exploiting right i mean that
you know you can start off in whatever
some some
infinite subspace and end up at a neural
network that's basically just some
transformation of
every other solution that you would kind
of optimize to
so um have you found any clues in this
work on on how you might
uh how we might better constrain um
you know the initial starting point
space to be a bit more efficient and
exploit
these symmetries absolutely so in fact
there's this whole area that has grown
up in the last several years and that
i'm very much you know
uh part of and really believe in of
symmetry based learning
where what you try to do is understand
why are the symmetries of the world
that you're trying to model and how
should they you know how should they be
reflected in the symmetries of the
network right
and a classic example of this is
confidence right translation symmetry
right
you include that in the network and it
you know it really buys you a great
reduction in sample complexity
so part of the answer that that to this
that comes from my paper and i allude to
that
briefly is that what you can now do is
you can encode
into your kernel the same symmetries
that you were encoding to the network
before
right what i should do right i should
have the same ability to encode
knowledge in particular knowledge of
symmetries and some people would say
that at the end of the day that's all
there is
into the kernel in the same way that i
do into neural networks and in a way
like
i remember like through the decades
there was always this contest between
the neural network people trying to hack
the architecture and the kernel people
trying to hack the kernel
right and in some ways the advantage of
new networks is that it's easy to put
knowledge into it but what this
you know what what this paper shows is
like how you can put exact
at this point you if you tell me you
know i have created a convent
by encoding into a translational
symmetry i know how to
do that in a kernel or other kinds of
symmetry which we have incorporated into
neural networks that can also be
incorporated into kernels and so on
forgive me forgive me i wasn't i wasn't
clear enough what i was asking more is
you can imagine you can start at many
random points in a space you follow a
trajectory to some optimum
what i was saying is if you look at the
trajectories over many different random
starting points
can we learn anything by comparing those
trajectories to one another
that might lead us to more advanced
symmetry representations
i think we can learn some things but
others we can't
right so there's the knowledge that is
encoded in the initial network
and the problem of course is that
knowledge is insufficient which is why
you need data
right so at some point you have no
choice i think but to randomize over
your starting points
because you truly don't know what the
weight should be so some of i know
you can put all our knowledge in and you
can put it interactively by running the
argument seeing what happens
but at some point unless there's nothing
to learning you don't need the data
some of that is unavoidable now do we
learn something from what happens
you know in the past we learn some
things but not others
so if i started a bunch of random points
and and the paths
are similar in some ways that's actually
a powerful hint
right and i can learn from that and
maybe what i do next is i now start from
a narrower you know more constrained
architecture
because i don't need those degrees of
freedom anymore and that's again
right that's one side but the other side
is that red alert right
you shouldn't mistake what happened with
the paths going from one architecture
from what could happen with all possible
architectures right
there's probably different architectures
that would have different paths so
you know what i would suggest is
something like don't just and you know
people do this of course you know and
there's like meta you know learning and
rml and whatnot it's like
you should try as many different
architectures as you can given the time
allowed
and what is actually most interesting
you know they're all useful but the most
interesting is not what happens
with different paths from different
random starting points in the same
architecture
but what are the similarities that you
get when you start from very different
architectures that's the part that i
really want to know
just a quick one to close out by the way
the symmetry thing's really interesting
we had professor max welling on he's the
the king and overlord of symmetries and
models and you know i mean recently he
was involved in the
the se3 transformer i think indirectly
but um
i i guess what i want to get to is um
the more i learn about machine learning
and ai the more disappointed i am
because you know
you've just given us a demonstration
which should be disappointing to many of
us that
indeed neural networks just interpolate
between the input points i mean francois
chile always used to say they were
glorified hash tables and in his measure
of intelligence paper which i think is
quite cool you know he said that you can
you can reason about um
uh you know intelligence as being a
function of the conversion efficiency of
information and also the
you know the the generalization and the
kind of you know the
the experience and the priors and so on
and of course there is this um
uh bias variance trade-off but i suppose
should we be disappointed i mean i'm
really excited about you know that you
said the group was was the
evolutionaries and we had kenneth
stanley on and i
i love open-endedness and
population-based methods and chalet
talks about neural programmed search and
yeah where are we going to discover ai
are we
you know agi are we anywhere close to it
i don't think we're close to it but in
answer to your question i think there's
actually two ways to look at this
one of them pessimistic and one of them
optimistic right
but i think both of them actually have
consequences for
where we go with our research the
pessimistic view which in some ways is
the more obvious one
is that wow you know in the 70 years of
machine learning in ai we haven't gotten
very far
right and that may well be the case
right it may well be the case that you
know at the end of the day all these
methods are just variations on nearest
neighbor
right and then and then if you really
want to do representation learning
we really need different ideas and i
think there's a lot of research to be
done there we need people pursuing
different ideas
not great in descent not background
again i'm all for greatness in the
backdrop but i don't think they'll give
us the representation like
what are some of these ideas again i
mentioned some of these in the paper
things like predictive coding of course
genetic algorithms
uh structure mapping you know the more
advanced forms of analogy there's
actually a lot to explore there
but unfortunately most of it is not
being explored these days because
you know deep learning has sucked up all
the oxygen so that's the pessimistic
view which means we have a lot of work
to do
it also means that we have a very
exciting time ahead of us because
there's all these great things to be
discovered right so
you know i'm jazzed if that's the answer
right as a machine learning researcher
right there's
there's lots to do and it'll be big
there's another view of this which in
some ways is
i mean it's the more optimistic one and
i also find it very intriguing
which is uh maybe that's all there is
maybe you don't need more maybe the
brain is also just doing
similarity-based learning in fact a lot
of psychologists will tell you that's
exactly what you know like and you know
douglas
tater of course there's a has a whole
book about this and what not
maybe you know we've just been
overestimating intelligence because it's
so mysterious to us
what we have in our brains is just a
more sophisticated form
of doing this thing of memorizing the
data and you know maybe you can look at
all of knowledge even all of science
says
that's all you're doing is you're
memorizing your examples and then
transforming and composing them in some
way
and this is of course is brilliantly
good news because it means we're
actually a lot closer to agi
than we think we are so either way i
think uh things look pretty interesting
that's always been one of my uh fears is
that if we or not fear but just
pondering is that if we learn too much
about ourselves we're going to figure
out people aren't intelligent either
no but they are well they i think look
uh
i think some of this is true that once
we understand intelligence it will lose
its mystery
right and we will not overestimate it as
much as we used to but i think
we will be more mature as a species when
when we do that right
there's nothing wrong with that i mean
look the reality is intelligence does
amazing things
right it doesn't have to do them you
know we could we as a species can still
be proud of our accomplishments even if
it turns out
that intelligence is not that big of a
deal and by the way you know to get back
to this notion of the master problem i
think that once we understand the brain
it's i think overwhelmingly likely that
we will understand that
most of it is just evolutionary cludges
that don't need to be there
so we'll be able to build brains that
are as good as ours but way
simpler right and again we know it's
from the level of the molecular biology
right i've heard distinguished you know
molecular biologists tell me that like
you know you know only people who don't
know anything about molecular biology
could believe in intelligent design
because what goes on in the cell is such
a pile of crap
or like if somebody else said nature
doesn't refactor its code right this
thing of refactoring your code
does not exist in nature so imagine what
the code is like right
so you know i don't think once we find
out that the brain
if we do find out that the brain is
simpler than we thought i i don't think
that's a bad thing i don't think it
would be a great thing
a bunch of plural code yeah i have a
feeling that
we won't ever understand it we had a guy
on from oxford university last week
talking about biologically plausible
neural networks and
he's recreated you know these networks
with temporal spiking dynamics and
he's noticed all of this emerging
phenomena i think it will be a case of
we'll create some very complex dynamics
which will emerge but
we won't necessarily understand them but
anyway
professor pedro domingos it's been an
absolute pleasure sir thank you very
much for coming on our podcast
yeah this was great thanks for having
thank you